Kylie Jenner is baring it all I love it
the 21 year old took to Instagram on
Tuesday to share a pic of herself and
boyfriend Travis Scott from an upcoming
Playboy spread in the sexy shot the
reality star appears naked rocking
nothing but a cowboy hat as she leans in
against Travis who is shirtless but is
wearing pants which is more than we can
say for Kylie I just love my body yep
Kylie bears her bum in the sneak peak
shot she captioned the pic quote when
Houston meets LA Playboy hashtag coming
soon I'm having so much fun I'm excited
about it
playboy also shared these three pics on
Instagram which show a red lift kylie
hugging travis the mag wrote alongside
the shots quote wild in love i am
obsessed with it a source tells ET that
the couple will be featured in Playboy's
fall 2019 issue dubbed the pleasure
issue Kylie has always been a fan of
Playboy and was honored to do the shoot
the source also revealed that Travis was
a creative director for the issue quote
the couple wanted to celebrate things
that bring them joy with this issue as
well as showcase their love for one
another the photos will be like nothing
you've ever seen the couple do together
before of course Kylie isn't the first
person in her famous family to pose for
Playboy
her sister Kim covered the risque mag in
December 2007 posing for Playboy was a
huge challenge for me but in the end I'm
so extremely happy that I did it but in
2014
Kylie's momager Kris Jenner said she
would never strip down for the mag even
though she did do her own sexy shoot
just for fun back in 2007 me without any
clothes last summer I posted those
bikini photos because I thought it was
so inspirational for someone you know in
their 50s to you know have some
motivation and say wow you know anybody
can at least try and put a bathing suit
on as for the rest of the fam Chloe went
nude for PETA
Kendall's bared it all as a model
and courts gone nude just for herself
well her business posing in the buff for
her lifestyle site Poosh
[Music]